I guess the Detroit cell keeps a concept
in San Francisco he's been running as a
pop up last nine months I want a wine
bar I might have said why no why bar
final wine bar I said square pie guys
happened after marks pop-up one night we
went to the page to get drinks and just
kind of talked about what we wanted to
do and the the level of I guess
enjoyment we wanted our guests to have I
think marks had an idea for a restaurant
for a long time like my whole career has
been in restaurants essentially and I've
always known that I wanted to start
something it just took someone else's
kind of like original idea to get us off
the ground but yeah we've like every
Thursday Friday since September we've
been in vinyl boom what's up everyone
welcome to simulation I'm your host Don
sockin very excited to be talking about
the square pie guys modern pizza we have
mark Schecter and Danny Stoller joining
us on the show hi guys
thanks for having thank you thanks for
coming on really appreciate it
I'm so pumped for this episode is so
great that Mario introduced us to you
and walk this over to your restaurant
that's just a block away from here on a
mission in seventh and beautiful
downtown SF and for those that don't
know they actually did this all in ten
months
mark Schecter and Danny stole our
cofounders of square pie guys a new
Detroit style pizza joint our mission of
seventh in downtown SF which went from
being a pop-up to brick-and-mortar in
just 10 months and you can find the
links in the bar below square pie guys
calm Instagram calm for size square pie
guys it was so delicious demoing the
different styles of pizza that you guys
have you have a very unique style with
what you do and it's already popping and
taken off let's uh let's start things
off with what are your thoughts in the
direction of our world it's kind of
[ __ ] it's pretty [ __ ] that's a
that's why I feel I don't know I think I
I racked my brain all time the way I
carry myself is I just want to do good
and like be good to people I care about
try to put like love out in the world
but that's pretty much all I thought I
could control like politics all these
other factors that people spend a lot of
time focusing on and working on like I
just feel like they're they've already
spelled out of control like global
warming studies all those things people
are saying like we're it's too late it's
like so much to think about a day and I
just try not to think about it and just
focus on doing good myself and that's
pretty much all I can do I think we have
time I think and I think that's why mark
and I are good business partners because
he's nice to people in the micro and I
try to be well I don't know if I try to
be nice to people in the macro but I do
think there's a lot of opportunity for
change I think we're seeing the change
hopefully in our political system and I
think there is a big shift politically
with the baby boomers generation and I
I'm very hopeful that we'll see that
change happening is like more outspoken
younger people get the mic and have the
ability to make influence and like use
means of communication like YouTube like
Twitter like social media all the other
things like ALC
I guess does a good example I think
there is opportunity for change and I
don't think it's too late if we get it
done in the next five years otherwise
what's what's happening what's the five
years I just think that if we can start
kicking the change off now when we like
there is still some ways that we can
make drastic changes and improve global
warming fix some of the political
systems get rid of some of the things
like the electoral college that are very
outdated fix some of the ways that votes
are assigned and suppress that gives
people that actually have political
power that have like progressive ideals
access then we'll be in a better place
it's always interesting hearing how
especially someone people that are
starting a small business
have what
view is on the direction of our world we
definitely have our ability to make the
change that we wish to see we're gonna
do it slowly over time all right now
what about the journey so who were you
guys growing up how did you guys even
get interested in where you're at today
well I think some that we both have
bonded on any stuff but as a bunch is
like we're kind of both like fat kids
which I don't know in a weird way it
probably built up the personal and today
like had to figure out ways to defend
myself while still without like going
into a hole and being all alone so
develop like humor as a defense
mechanism and yeah
certain things that I now see playing on
my adult life or I'm like oh that's kind
of where that came from but with that
said I've always loved food and grew up
in New York and I mean there's no
there's no shortage of really good pizza
there's plenty of really bad pizza to
like don't don't get it twisted in New
York he's known for pizza but there's
way more bad pizza than there is good
but there's many more great pizza places
there then you can find almost anywhere
else so that's a big part of it but yeah
I don't know
pretty happy-go-lucky playing a lot of
sports just didn't really know where I
fit in all the time
I was also affected it's funny because I
asked you before this started about like
a book that I'm trying to read right now
and then I saw my girlfriend about it
and I think one thing I worked on right
now I don't know if I'm successfully
working on it or if it's perceptible but
I really like being right and I really
like being smart at things and I'm kind
of like cuz I've been in and out there
beat my whole life and we don't have a
lot of time for self work right now but
like stripping it away I think it comes
down to you when I was younger I wasn't
cool people didn't think I was funny
we're like sexy but I could always be
smart and so that was my like that was
my like well if I have nothing else I
can be smarter than them
and then like I think that's that's what
I'm shearling when I was like you can
still be smart and be wrong but I think
you were also kind of like how we got
yes starting a pizza restaurant that
looks good so I was I grew up in it we
both grew up Jewish families marks from
the East Coast my parents are in the
East Coast foods a big part of I think
everyone's culture but like Jews if you
said you eat if you're happy you hungry
pretty much pizza however you eat it
like there's a lot of food in the Jewish
culture and my parents both work
full-time and I was like four years old
and I kept waking them up on weekends
and they're like here's how you make
cereal stop waking us up and then like a
couple months later like literally I
think I was five when I there was like
started making scrambled eggs they're
like put a like a little push stool on
the electric stove and like scrambled
eggs so I was sort of empowered to feed
myself at a young age and that that was
like a big part of my independence and
then I think later in life I realized
that cooking was something I wanted to
do and so I went to call it for a little
bit
study journalism didn't think that that
was the right path for me moved back
home I was like college dropout smoked a
lot of weed like a lot of weed and my
parents like you can't be a pothead a
dropout and I'm employed and live at
home so like get a [ __ ] job and the
job that I could get while still being a
pothead was working in restaurants and
to the point about like I think a lot of
like kids when they're younger that are
overweight it's also linked to just kind
of like unhappiness and like general
disregard for self and there's this
moment pretty quickly where it's like to
the point about being smart is like oh
I'm good at cooking like I have like an
inherent advantage or like inherently
there's like intuition that I have that
makes me feel really good about myself
and time also passes really quickly and
so there's one of those things there's
like once I started cooking I had a part
of my life that I could feel
about myself horror and so it's like
that's pretty obvious choice for a
career yeah we never really spoke like
about that's for the appointment that's
pretty much when I started like I start
making feats at home like two years ago
and that's pretty much the Eureka moment
for me was the same thing like time
passed quickly and I felt good about
what I was doing and people liked it and
I was like I wonder how I could do this
more and see it like maybe make money
off of her figure out how I could sell
food hey Mike so the last 10 years in
tech sales well no it's more like you
like something I could do career why not
but like that's yeah so then it was a
path in the restaurant business mostly
so it's weird because I was 18 when I
started cooking went to culinary school
after a couple years and the last I mean
honestly the last time I worked
full-time in a restaurant for any period
of time was 25 and then I got a job at a
startup got a job at another startup
worked my last role and at Mark and I
started a pizza restaurant and then like
last week I realized as a working chef
again you're working chef yeah yeah and
then okay and then with Mark than it was
tech sales last ten years and then yes I
was like 23 seven years but no I mean
well one thing Danny Danny's last job
we'll work with one of my really good
friends I I'm lucky I don't know some
twist of fate that I have a lot of the
same friends that I grew up with from my
home town like my tight and it's circle
a lot of them are out here working so
people have known my whole life and one
of those people was Danny's old
co-worker hmm so that's how he met me
Matt two years ago we actually met while
I was still interviewing for that job
right mark was like I think just are
just kicking off the pizza thing cool
like literally our old marketing manager
that job
she was breathless she was like he's in
tech sales but his passionate speech is
such a San Francisco thing but then like
we had the same sense of humor we worked
a couple events together
and we were like like we could make make
the same type of joke
how did you figure out when you're
making pizza what the thing was that
would separate you from other people me
yeah I you know it's weird I'll it's
always been weird to me cuz like I don't
have a culinary background and I didn't
spend a ton of the years like making
bread at home before I moved into Pizza
I just kind of there's something about
me were like not everything like plenty
of things I've been like standoffish and
weird and like afraid to try but there
are certain things where I'm just like
[ __ ] it like if I fail I don't really
care so I'm saying then pizza I just put
the put the flour and the water in the
bowl I read some like a couple books got
some recipes started working off of
those and then perfecting them and like
learning what the dough felt like or if
a dough felt this way then I baked it it
came out good it came out bad I just
started like building this internal log
of those trials and errors and just went
for it and then again wasn't had no
qualms about being like hey people come
over eat this pizza if it's bad tell me
like I'm not gonna be offended I don't I
don't think I'm good I just started at
this like I had no pretense going in so
I just was very gung-ho about making it
and I guess I read the right books and
had sort of have the the palette built
in from growing up eating such good
pizza in New York and you just kind of
worked out and then then I started to
get more serious I asked our mutual
friend to start a restaurant me back
then yeah because I was out in a weird
place I was think I moved out here with
a girl we were engaged and then it went
really south like really quick
unexpectedly
and it put me in this sort of
existential crisis of like what am I
gonna do like I knew I didn't enjoy
doing software sales was pretty someone
actually listened to a podcast this
morning it's called Pizza City USA it's
by pretty famous like food writer who
like loves pizza runs food tours in
Chicago his interviewing guy named
Anthony Falco who is this big name in
the pizza world and basically he's like
in when you're selling pizza you're in
like the happy business like nobody buys
insurance from you and says like thank
you so much as insurance is making me so
happy you know so it was a very similar
thing with like software sales like no
one was like wow like I'm so
to buy this small business marketing so
far like you saved my life thank you so
much you know so you didn't get anything
you were basically just like you had to
kind of be like johnny-on-the-spot or
have the right timing to make a deal and
you made the deal and people were still
like not half they were too annoyed at
you there it's like fine I'll buy it you
gave me good price there was no nothing
came of it that was like fulfilling that
for the self so then do pizza was really
big game and like I don't know I'm I'm a
people person I really Drive off at like
giving you something watching you eat it
and you tell me and either which way
like if you tell me you don't like it a
cool at least we have an interaction we
could like bond and have a human
connection versus just like being this
ambiguous person the other end of the
phone trying to get you to buy something
so it kind of felt pretty logical at all
as it all like it happened at once that
it all played out yeah yeah I think like
also mark and I have played a lot with
like division of responsibilities like I
like talking to the guests I really love
getting to know them but I think like
what gets me out of bed in the morning
is all of the processes that go into
like the behind the scenes work of that
like I love building systems and
building business and like coming up so
many questions about that and right
before we get there
let's do how then 10 months ago did you
guys go okay we're gonna come up with
our own unique brand or own unique
pizzas it wasn't that so go back a bit
yeah Howie campus tattoo marks like so
listen when I was 12
no but we so I did that I made beats at
home asked our friend to start a
restaurant of me he basically told me
that I was crazy which in hindsight I
realized I was I was like oh let's start
a restaurant like you know what you're
doing I kind of have a good product
maybe who knows like ten people over
like three dinner parties and said it's
really good also keep in mind like this
guy like me hit like has theoretically
spent his whole career learning his own
style his own
and he could open his own rest of to see
hopefully one day for him but also like
I was just not even like very excited
and he was like you're crazy and he put
like very casually was like go see if he
could even work in a restaurant I'm like
I said just broken up with this girl I
had like nothing else to do in my life a
lot of more free time than I expected I
would be having and so I did I like went
out and just apply the jobs on
Craigslist and the first time I landed
was someplace in Orinda which was like a
[ __ ] and the the cook that like I
guess the kitchen manager at the time
that night that he was training me he
like carried this huge tray of pasta
they poured it out of the boiling water
a boiling water into this pan and he
dropped it on the floor and like picked
it up put it back in the pan and then he
ate it and I was like oh that's gross
and then the owner after their ship just
like you work pretty hard we want you to
work here and I was like I'll get back
to you and then I never got that cuz I
was like that is but I know right but I
was lucky I landed a job at Pizza hacker
in the mission and then from there like
kind of was working in some really good
kitchens and and then started doing
feasts lis pop-ups and basically just
like kept gaining confidence I'm like
yes like yes
you know staircase kind of like just up
and up and up and did my own pop-up in
in March of last year at vinyl wine bar
you know and then enter Danny so then I
was working so I was working at an
innovation agency that does consulting
work with big food brands and I was on a
project that was actually more of like
an incubator project so a very well
funded Pizza project where I was the
person who's essentially over hauling
all of their recipes and working hand in
hand with our strategist to kind of
create a brand that could scale
relatively quickly in the pizza world so
I was sort of deep into like what it
meant to start a restaurant in pizza
world in the pizza world and like what
it meant to like sort of create recipes
and all those things and so mark and I
started driving on that mark did an
event
I like introduced him to be part of this
networking group I was part of he did an
event with them and he was like hey you
roped me into this now you got to come
help me cook
you know he was very nice but he asked
me to help him work this event and
what's funny cuz I was like we have
other mutual friends at this point in
time who had helped me events and I paid
them obviously because I'm getting money
to do it right and I was like I'll pay
you and Danny was like I'm gonna I'm not
a cool chef or hire anymore that was for
free but then like you really can I pay
you any of others yeah yeah and I was
like no but I want to start a business
with you right oh I think this is so we
I we've had twice now in my house like a
fourth of July barbecue and mark was
like you know dude
Detroit style pizza fast casual don't
steal the idea like that like that was
his thought that was his like business
idea yeah and then I think a couple
weeks later we started talking about
like I thought it was like you know a
restaurant background I think I could
probably bring some good value to the
partnership and I thought it was a solid
idea and I was like I've been ready to
work for myself for the past four years
I just haven't known what they're like
the right thing was to start timeing
right there yeah so alright so then when
you guys are putting this - this is like
the summer of last year 2018 yeah okay
so then what is it like for there's so
many people that are watching from
around the world that have interest in
food that have interest in
entrepreneurship what is it like to go
from this fast casual Detroit style
pizza like in your head and you're
practicing right so you have practice
built up which is huge as well yeah
practice right also then you're like now
how does this actually become a
brick-and-mortar how does that process
happen
I mean well going to the very beginning
I I go back to what I just saying before
like you got a it's one thing to like
make a product or have an idea and
create it in a bubble like you have to
get it in front of people yeah you have
to do it yeah like we just like we
literally like we just [ __ ] did it
yeah we created an LLC and my LegalZoom
it's not that expensive you just go to
igloo it's like it's all there for you I
was like I guess what a lot of these
things I was like I didn't think I could
do them but then as you start to
research them and that's I think that's
a big difference in us like you're like
it's the informations out there I'm
gonna do it
right I'm like I can't do that and then
I like learn again through the trauma
okay you could do that like it's not
that hard or it's something crazy it's
not that unbelievable
it's like everything's risk like saying
other jobs at risk but after you guys
get an LLC filed then do you guys need
to do something like identify a location
do you need to get a permit so mark mark
had a pop up because pizza hacker
started at vinyl wine bar so why don't
why don't I think guys like
unintentionally or intentionally
launched a couple beats of restaurants
in San Francisco so Pete's hacker he
didn't launch it with vinyl he would
like go around on the mission with this
Jerry rate of and that he built out of
like a Weber grill he like welded steel
together well it was a foam it was a
foam he dome that he made didn't wasn't
this yeah he made it calls it the
framing Weber he made his wacky oven
went around the mission he's got a cool
story Tim but then from there he went I
think went to vinyl wine bar
a guy named Casey who has a place in the
mission uh a Mission Bay had a food
truck for a while before the food truck
was that vinyl so if I know is his like
known quantity they had this like
countertop basically bread or a pizza
oven and when I was working at Pizza
hacker I wasn't quick enough to work on
their busy nights they would send me to
run the pop-up which was slow but that's
how I got introduced to the owner of
that place in the crew and mooner Pizza
hacker and basically fast forward a year
cuz that was like summer of 2017 a year
on from that like they're like a little
less than a year on less less spring
Pete's hacker like left and I knew it
because I had worked there so I reached
out let me got the venue so I mean
there's some yeah there's a lot of like
throughout this whole path there's a lot
of really good timing
yeah great timing synchronicities these
types of things again even like all the
way to your f fiance yeah yeah yeah yeah
that breakup you know ok so then but
then now you know once you're doing all
the you know the fight your fret you
think this is complicated that you have
to you have to do défilé LLC is to find
this location you have to get the right
permitting you have to design a menu you
have to figure out where you're sourcing
ingredients from it has
a really good location that is gonna get
you foot traffic you have to design your
website and your social accounts I mean
this is like big stuff you have to do
the systems design outside of things so
the thing is like to the point about I
we talked about rapid prototyping before
like we figured out what we needed to
have what [ __ ] we had to have together
before we started and what we could
figure out after antenna was and during
you know it's just that simple like Mark
had an Instagram account called square
PI guy we needed a name I was like I
like square PI guys cuz there's two of
us now Mark was like that was it that
was hey yeah we had a location because
mark was doing a round PI pop up but you
know what we found I think when we did a
night or like a week of research where
we found seven or eight other venues
that would have had the exact same setup
as we had at vinyl and a heartbeat
yeah it's harder it's really hard to run
a restaurant
in the city there's a lot of places yeah
like your licenses require them to have
a restaurant and so anything they can do
to outsource it those owners yeah yeah
so I would say no one should ever have a
problem in the city trying to find the
restaurant whether or not it'll have the
right foot traffic or the right buzz
right people are gonna come there that's
another kind of I don't happen to be
like but it was yeah but I mean I had I
had Pete my original experiment still
exists Pizza Man 4:20 goes just a lot a
long silly story is just like a joke and
that kind of blew up and then all my
friends when I was post pictures of like
square pizzas when I was making I was
making the trade style I'd like someone
hired me to do a wedding that I did Troy
style for I had another pop up through
the company called VC I did Detroit
style for because I was always like this
has to be the next thing because
everyone all the pizzerias in the city
essentially do the same style of like
really nice individual size pies Leone
ownio poll right and it you're like a
deck oven they all do the same kind of
ice so I was like if we're gonna start a
business like my pop-up that I was doing
was was decently successful but there
was ever gonna be anything bigger
to your point like we had a
differentiate and I knew
you know that this would be the one so I
was doing that and then I would make
these pizzas and people would be like
what are these square pies and was like
okay I'll make another Instagram just to
satisfy my annoying friends who are like
you can't put square pizza on pizza man
so then I got my guy it was like such a
you know it wasn't that much like prior
thought it was I read it on the website
that it used to be in Detroit they used
to hold the automotive parts with the
square and that's where the square pizza
it all goes back to Sicily yeah there's
a big Sicilian population in Detroit
they saw these pans interesting yeah
whoa yeah interesting yeah okay and then
all right so now let's get into what you
know take us more closer tours of like
launch date and all this type of stuff
yeah so we were planning we opened an
LLC we did like a pizza tour of the East
Bay on bikes we did some chatting about
what a restaurant would be and then mark
made dough on a Tuesday and I showed up
on a Thursday with another buddy of ours
and cook pizza because he was going to
Italy for a wedding and then we did that
and I think we sold like 18 pies one
night and 20 years something it wasn't a
lot but it was close to I think what
some of the best nights mark had done he
has a round pie pop-up and some of that
was likely like carryover from people
who are like Jeff just catching on to
his pop-up and then the next week I was
at a town so Marc ran it without me I
was in Seattle and it was like an even
bigger night and then I came back and I
think the first night together was like
the end of September we sold out like we
didn't have enough pants to keep up with
demand and we just like you know
Instagram is a platform like design for
yeah yeah there's got a lot of tags on
your posts and people can search by
those tags right yeah but it's also just
like it's a visual platform pizza you
eat with your eyes like it's like you
with your eyes like that's like a
perfect marriage you know it's different
it looks very different from any other
pizza it doesn't look super different
than the other pieces so you guys are
getting a lot of incoming
traffic from Instagram yeah that's
George that's huge I sure have people
posting about it yeah and in getting
other people to come to the
brick-and-mortar looking I know creates
hype to like it creates this idea of
like like anyone can post a picture of
the like hundreds of like neo Neapolitan
pies in the city and it doesn't like you
don't feel like you're missing out
because you can get it at the place on
your yeah thanks for pulling this up
Ronnie yeah the Instagram is on fire you
guys are just crushing it I think you're
at like over it's like six thousandths
or about seven five five K I don't watch
it like every second every day as well
yeah you guys are crushing it that's a
good picture just great yeah grandsanta
by scripture okay so yeah so but yeah so
also yeah closer to yes that's that's
the little location the address again is
one one one oh five and seven one oh
seven seven
okay so then yeah so how does how does
it get all the way to the opening what
was going really well we we I used to
also do like breweries so we would go to
different breweries with the pop out we
just kind of run around the city and it
just kept building this momentum yeah
and basically Danny is the systems guy
and he kept building different systems
to accommodate that new demand we kept
ordering more and more pans but we
always sort of knew like around I mean
we started in September we always do we
wanted a restaurant ok October November
got really busy and then like December
we had bought more pans and then
immediately started selling out of those
pans and we were like man it's like I
think it's time and then I started
looking on Craigslist at different like
because Craigslist was just a treasure
trove of what's around so there was
places available we started looking at
different locations and it was it was
interesting because initially just like
almost anything you do and you like when
you're putting yourself out there the
first cup we looked at where shitholes
and asking for a crazy amount of money
and it needed a lot of work right so we
were like it's a hundred thousand to get
in the door but you need to extend the
hood really which could cost on another
right so like yeah we were like we're
never gonna do this you know like or how
are we gonna get the funding I mean we
had some ideas about how
vesser's and like how much we thought we
could raise but you never know and like
we had a couple I have a friend who is
like done really well in the tech world
who told us we could like raise two
million dollars and we were like whoa
and we wasted a month like trying to
sell ourselves as as like a tech company
that got nowhere and everyone's like
you're a basically unproven restaurant
and you're asking how much at what
valuation an acquisition and like I
think there's like there like this slide
has to say this and I was like mark like
we're not that why should we put that on
there yeah so but it's up because like
to millions of sexy amount of money to
raise for your first business show right
yeah well I mean yeah we just kept all
the while we were still just doing the
pop-up like well that's a really
important lesson actually for those
listening is that not everything is
something to get venture angel funding
totally especially when you're already
having this slow proven record just keep
going on that slow pace and then you'll
prove yourself like you're doing and
I'll tell you something else you know
like on the investors that we have for
people that we have not barely known for
a year they were customers at the pop-up
that you saw our passion so how we
interacted love the food and we're like
hey I want to bet and these two guys
they're first-time investors would not
call it angel or they're like you did a
micro seed round yeah yeah
like what like 100 thousand ish lures or
four Wow and that was enough to get the
foot in the door into this yeah
it means door front restaurants are
expensive yeah so that was enough to
bridge you into the foot in the door of
the of the yeah and so what is what is
rent at locations like you guys have why
do you guys have like a 800 square feet
no thousand 2500 oh my gosh we're paying
well cause it's like the second floor
sleeping to a be a square foot
280 a square foot yeah and there's that
50 it's actually - it is that's like
pretty high or no that's like dirt cheap
for San Francisco Jersey presa we're
offering that yes yeah for that area
okay
and then so then you guys also have to
do an interior design as well or did it
come pretty well like that's that's part
of this like to your point there's a lot
of community behind us like yeah my very
first pop-up going back to the arm you
friend his coworker the guy I grew up
with we my after I asked him to open a
restaurant he told me to go work in a
restaurant I bought this little pizza
oven and you put like these tiny wood
chips in it it's like a shitty metal box
but it can make like a real a real pizza
you can't make it can't make 20 of them
in a row because it loses heat but it
could make like one so I was like this
is good enough I called up a bar in
Oakland where I lived in Berkeley the
time and they like let me do a pop-up
there and one of the girls one of those
someone a customer is a wonderful woman
hailey met me she loves pizza she
doesn't know what hailey has a cool
story herself and just like chatting me
up at that pop-up like Papua number one
July it was like July 17th 2017 fast
forward to now we've been friends she's
come seen square pie guys really work
and she has a she's an architect has a
design firm hadn't done a restaurant
asked if we could like work out a deal
where dated our design and like on trade
for some pizza and some money and like
there you go awesome so like the
synchronicities yeah again and she
hooked us up with a builder she worked
with yep who could do fast work like we
were literally like they were like gonna
cut wood and we're like measuring we're
doing a massive pizza oven we're to get
oven yeah and that's expensive it was
expensive
those are like what 50 K it was 25 25
yes if we got a bigger oven it could
have gone up to 35 total for all three
Wow
and we financed it yeah it's a big chunk
of change every month to come out of the
bank account but it's a bigger chunk of
change to take out of your business yeah
and cash flow is hardest in the first
couple months of the restaurant so so
now how is that happening then so you
guys get all these pieces together for
the inside how do you how do you know
what where you're gonna be sourcing your
food from from for the pizzas and how do
you have designed a menu that is
adequate enough how did you figure out
how much a pie costs to get to
compensate for the cost of it plus also
give you guys enough money to actually
yeah right grow as a business I mean art
art in science right yeah like I think a
lot of it was like
some of it was obvious like like even
little things like a oil pickup service
like we inherited a fryer when we took
over the space and I wanted the oil to
go away but we didn't have an oil pickup
service so I set up an oil service and
then we were like [ __ ] we gotta clean
this fryer do we need towels like let's
get a towel I mean it was like then it
was bigger things like we kind of worked
backwards right like we took over a
space that was operational if we it'd in
the window of time between when we
signed the lease and when the prior
owner took all of his equipment now we
could have literally gotten permitted to
be open with different equipment than we
were planning to open with it's like
basically kind of like pulled the wool
over the eyes of the city and had a
restaurant that was like a turnkey
restaurant yeah where the fire
department would give us a check off the
Health Department would give us a check
off before we ever did anything else
before we even took possession of the
building but we wanted to do it right
and so then it was like a work backward
list of like we need the fire we need a
Health Department permit to open that's
like the last permit we need the fire
check off to get the health permit yeah
we need the oven to be installed you
test our recipes and our the menu but
just to be fair I don't know if you're
not giving yourself credit on purpose
like you have a pretty deep background
in doing yeah I mean I project managed
open yeah just some I mean we open now
that Danny wrote like it's incredible
menu brief I mean we don't we had
theories I mean like I again going back
to Instagram it's you see that what's
the rest of the country is doing in
terms of the type of food that you want
to sell so like this place says that
that place says this could we do chicken
couple I kind of like the place I grew
up with at home could we do a burger
like this but you know it's like and you
take it and you rip on it just like I
need like art you take so this guy has
this kind of rap what about what this
beat and this artist like you just kind
of make those things in your mind and
you try it you put them out in the world
and if you're good but then it's like
it's like the commercial is
commercialization right so like I do is
a huge name in the Bay
they have like a an innovation pipeline
I think I've worked for three companies
that now use something similar and so we
started with a hypothesis we figure out
a way to like partially I might we might
we don't I'm on an India right like how
am i we and then we like we did kind of
some rapid prototyping of the of the
products we brought in ingredient like
we ordered a lot of food from our
vendors some of them we already had in
place from the pop-up pop-up right other
ones we knew are the sources local for
food so the restaurant world there's
like the mom-and-pop restaurants who
black from my cash-and-carry restaurant
Depot and you know maybe a local Cora
store there's like the huge like
vertically integrated like hotels have
buying negotiated buying agreements with
like Cisco food services of America yeah
and then there's like the chef driven
restaurants that use a mixture of
vendors so we're two doors over from
birdsong and they buy from all three
major produce vendors in the city they
buy from
I write food service which is like kind
of like paper goods not the same as by
right the grocery store same company
that no I really did completely distinct
interesting not even at all related not
overly what I write is like a term that
was used like there's a by Wright
liquors in like Ocean Beach that it's
not related to them either it's just a
term that was a popular in the Bay Area
she have to get a source for everything
from from the actual packaging all the
way to the actual and oh yeah just laugh
at packaging yeah
what's your PI guys we're not 12 because
we got these from China like yeah oh
yeah we're only asking for at least this
final line I sign the contract saying we
have by eight thousand dollars worth of
these boxes yeah and we kicked off a
design spam yeah holy crap yeah oh
that's crazy
like we're gonna open June 15th and they
were like pizza boxes will be here June
27 I guess we're gonna open shoot yeah
okay buddy came all the way from China
on a barge yes crazy yeah so cheer about
sourcing the one thing that I love about
the restaurant industry is there's
someone whose job it is to sell you
something at the right price for you and
for them yeah so like with this pizza
box like we buy from a paper distributor
and they also sell us like gloves and
garbage bags on it like they sell like a
hundred and seventy count cases of
tampons because restaurants need tampons
because you know guess yeah are people
using the bathroom yeah
and so this the sales rep was like
what's gonna be your usage what can you
agree to pay for yeah what's it need to
look like and then he shops it around to
every vendor he has interesting and then
he was like he came back and he's like
overseas is gonna be the best price
that's gonna take three months to get
here damn and they're not gonna they're
not gonna fix it if if you don't like
how they do right and thankfully Danny
has a good friend who's an awesome
designer we gave her the logo we told
her what we wanted she put it together
and they're [ __ ] cool [ __ ] awesome
awesome yeah yeah yeah okay okay so now
now we talk about the actual pieces
themselves because this is how you
source ingredients is how you get the
actual box this is now this is a this is
a single serving pizza for one per two
people yeah share this and how many
total people you can eat it yourself I I
just wait six slice yeah how many oh
it's a horse list because it's for you
guys yeah normally it comes in normally
normally this box comes in
four Slice yes got it okay and then no
the bacon grease really well so this is
bacon and just like a cheese by a bacon
she's probably bacon yeah okay and then
this is someone to chew depends on yeah
most someone's really hungry you sell
like a lot of like you know couples have
come in to the pop up in the restaurant
they split one maybe have a size so yeah
and then the the cost yeah we're a
single pie like this we start 16 cheese
or build your own cheese or build your
own yeah with a couple ingredients like
they'll Jerome is a the included price
is like what topping ones object yeah
and then each additional talking is
another buck or something yeah yeah and
I think our top high is at 23 right now
yeah because seasonal pizza local
ingredient is 22 a lot a lot of labor on
it as well yeah we include labor in our
pricing model because it's the Bay Area
yeah and this is one of your more simple
pies which is just a single ingredient
on a cheese pie yeah but it's still very
interesting that the crust this is the
most unique crust I think I've ever had
which is that you sprinkle cheddar
around the outside of the of the pan
yeah well it's like we the the pan
itself is kind of like sort of the depth
of the walls of that of that box in a
way if you if you could visualize that
and the dough sits down in the middle of
it and instead of like topping it and
leaving an edge like a round pie where
the crust is gonna rise you cover that
with cheese and as that dough Rises in
the oven it pushes out onto the hot wall
and essentially like fries the cheese
and then you all yeah and the the fat
splits out of the cheese rolls down to
the bottom of the pan you know got
crispy yeah yeah that's like crispy like
crunchy it's like all those things in
its like every style pizza in one bite
kind of you me that's how I and so again
this is one of the more just you know
cheese pie with bacon there's gonna
there's okay let's see what else you
guys brought
yeah it's like Christmas it's Christmas
you have celiac so this is like this is
our top seller this is ten dollars pop
yeah and I think this probably is the
one that likely helps us the most on
Instagram maybe in competition with the
ones we do like really cool sauce
drizzle drizzle
I mean a lot of the stuff we do is
intentional for for them for insert yeah
like our like I think the nice thing
about this pie is like you can make them
all look really [ __ ] cool yeah you
have a lot more control with it but like
I said I grew up and most places had
like flat greasy pepperoni and every now
and then and then I would go to a place
to have this like delicious copling
pepperoni which is like a pepperoni with
a natural casing and as the heats it
curls up and like traps all the grease
in there yeah and it's super it's super
good it's also like really visually
stunning too and you get these like
essentially pepperoni cups a brownie
cups would you mr. Graham loves
Instagram it loves like so much of
modern food I mean the Detroit style
pizza too is a facet of like yeah in
Detroit it's not Detroit style pizza
it's just square pizza or peaches pizza
yeah and so like that in and of itself I
think is a big part of yeah look like
why we're here yeah this is probably
like this this pies been on our menu
that since the beginning it's all work
yeah but it's like it's like our
California in a way I guess it's not
really California but it's like but just
the idea of broccoli on a pizza rock
what is it is it Italian sausage Italian
sausage roast we used to roast the
broccoli now we marinate it and it rose
a lot its own inner of it because there
ever is a little different it's like
we're like ricotta cream and then it
gets finished with slightly cooler cream
yes like again this is another thing
where I'm like I don't know don't do it
here what but some places that works I
do like cream with a bunch of different
cheeses in the cream and let's spread
that on the pie and then I'll be their
white sauce yeah yeah let's do the last
puppy too and then take a taste - this
is one that's not really on our menu but
I just kind of made it for you guys
so it's vodka sauce ooh with chorizo
what's your reason I think I tried this
one yeah yeah yeah vogue says so these
are the unique combinations that we're
talking about yeah you guys are
basically running combinatorics all over
your pee
talk about that talk about that a lot
like how can you be the most unique
Pizza yeah period all right how many
torques a freaking cool word yeah marks
gonna be history never gonna stop saying
hey go come pick the time do you guys
did you guys I'm gonna eat every single
day do you guys eat pizza we're actively
trying to eat less meat but it's hard
because you're also like trying to test
our recipes and finger things out Ron's
very excited crust piece here which oh
you want to know oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah take a bite at a time
yeah yeah of course yeah trees I'm take
one too and then let's throw which one
you want you want those cheese what
eikan-do on the bacon Branca figured Ron
Ron was more on the bacon on the bacon
side of things always look Ronnie on the
middle one the middle more please yeah
thank you he's everywhere so
yeah one of my favorite parts about
eating your pizza was that it was unique
it was a different experience I saw
different toppings I saw a different
crust I saw it in the form of a square
you know these are the you know the more
uniqueness yeah yeah the more separate
now mm-hmm I mean the nice thing is we
get to have a lot of fun yeah I feel
like one of our I think our second best
seller right now is the summer a little
take horn which I put on the brief and
then mark just [ __ ] nailed during
development which is like local corn
ricotta cream taco seasoning cotija some
like chopped cherry tomatoes like a
lotus it's in a low tank pizza but then
with tomatoes there's a mass and you
know yup and so then how does it work
then with with your like get walk us
through like the scible like it's the
chain for the for the for the chefs so
you have all of your actually even let's
take one step before that that part you
have to actually come in like you have
right now you're 4:00 to 10:00 p.m. on
using through Saturday and then Sunday
you're off but Monday you have to do all
your prep first starting Tuesday so what
is it I'm we've done this twice now
technically right so how is that like
then basically you have to come in and
make all the dough and prep all the
ingredients etc yes so tell us about
that process I mean it's not easy also
because we're also like building our
team so we're doing this as we are
people she's my training like training
is happening in stream with running the
restaurant it's not me pause to be like
your announcer yeah I had to work here
yeah I mean and simultaneously we're
building a lot of the back
systems like inventory like ordering
like prep lists like training materials
like what a prep schedule should look
like last Monday we came in and had to
prep literally everything from scratch
because we've done soft launches the
week prior but pretty much everything we
threw out on Thursday so he came in
Monday and made a lot of food yeah then
on Tuesday same thing fortunate enough
that there's a couple sauces we made
like Saturday that are still gonna get
on Saturn on Tuesday still gonna be
delicious and fresh so this today was a
lot of like doing a lot of we sold we
sold out of chicken wings and one night
on Thursday we sold all our chicken
wings we got more it on Thursday
sold out of them so we brought in a lot
more this I want Ron did you backup
vocals and all of our Instagram videos
square pizza guy who's conveniently
located south of market
experiencia
yeah changing the company now how this
is falling apart so beautiful just a
separation here would we pull it apart
mmm it looks good the fluffiness of the
dough yep the Jody of the melted cheese
are on top of it we're both patient I
love that [ __ ] now I'm turned on this
part this parts complicated so so then
how long does the dough how many days do
you get with the dough that you make and
then how many days do you give it to
sauce they yeah yeah that means to be
honest some of those things were sort of
learning like theirs I was his standards
for certain things that expire but like
but also we're so I mean right we don't
have issues with like
can we give this to last it's like how
quickly can we make it yeah like we like
for instance like we used to make well
how quickly we make dough right that's
you have to wait we're working on that
yeah we like you there's like a lot of
levers to play with right there's
temperature there's a percentage of
yeast there's like when you whether you
s-- let it all sit together as one pile
of dough whether you portion into the
pans let it rise like that and those are
variables that I didn't necessarily
think we'd still be playing with but it
makes sense now in hindsight because
obviously at the pop-up for example we
made I used to make the dough in the
basement of vinyl which is illegal so
don't tell anyway but yeah but it was
like at least the proper equipment like
a sink and whatnot but you know I would
make the dough I would sit in the fridge
for a couple days and ferment in a
different way then we're doing it now
and then we would put it in take it and
put it in my car and drive it to vinyl I
mean would like rise that day yeah so
like there was those variables worked
for that but we took that same recipe
over to here and it was different so we
just kind of had to learn from our new
setting ok and then in terms of like
actually having dough that's on the line
ready to go so what do you do you have
the little kind of like dough balls and
then you take the dough balls and you
turn that into you kind of push that
into the square that pan would you have
to happen that happens something happens
during the process and makes it make the
dough you get the order now no get the
order and the pan is ready to be cheesed
yes
okay so oh god it's so the dose oh you
have the dough in the piano so that big
difference a teen and you don't she's
the dough before you get to ordered
we've done that we happy we play with it
we could doesn't say that much time yeah
that's a fast we have higher chance I
mean at the pop-up at least when we
didn't sell I was like well we just
threw a like right we have all these
days it's just like an olive oil on
bottom a variance mom a little bit of a
small mouth okay and then you do the
pans and those are kind of stacked ready
- ready towards that nest yeah lids the
nest and you put them in the fridge and
then their refrigerated okay so the
order comes in you take it out I'm on
the line yeah okay and I read that that
it's a let's do
what's the one that we tried that had a
police to that one yeah had like I think
he had a grated Parmesan on top with the
spoiler that she's spicy Ellen with the
with the vodka sauce yeah it might have
been there yeah yeah and there was some
green on it yeah yeah okay so we try
basil traditionally you ever like
chiffonade basil or Terry we do so let's
take a more complicated pie like that
okay so we have a pie like that and now
I have a I have I'm by training I've
already made a bunch of these before but
you still have the list up of like the
other ingredients of how to make it yep
okay so what am I putting on the cheddar
all around the crust first yeah okay
then your sauce goes there and then
sauces and squeeze bottles and this is
everything from like a marinara to vodka
sauce to a pasta sauce vodka sauce the
ricotta cream the ground water cream and
then our classic red sauce and classic
red and then those are made in-house a
one-house and by the way one thing that
I always find interesting when I talk
people are like like oh how does your
sauce taste or that are like how do you
cook it or whatever like with pizza it's
just raw tomatoes like they're Ken
Tomatoes a company called Bianco
DiNapoli yeah that grow them up north
they're super delicious organic and we
just blend them together with oregano
and salt and that's it I think what I
did with oregano and salt and it cooked
now cooked on the pee on the pizza on
the pizzas are not preserving the
canning process partially cooks them
so right they're steamed to peel them
and then they're put in two cans of
juice and there's some but they're still
very fresh right they're essentially
hermetically sealed at that point okay
and then so then sauce it first yeah
okay cheddar first cheddar for you and
sauce and mozzarella okay there's one
ingredient that we put into the cheese
right now which is kale because kale is
getting too dark where would be like
cheddar sauce kale yeah ought it got it
okay cuz yeah that's the thing about
putting greens on top of pieces is that
you want it to be baked a little bit
less than depending on the greens are
you couldn't you could never make a roux
Galan
like that so mystic yeah for all those
that still want to try the combinatorics
maybe they can figure out how to get
arugula let me know what the square pie
guys know if you figure that one yeah
yeah yeah okay and then so then I'm
layering than the other ingredients
after yep after that after the
mozzarella okay and then and then once
that once all those ingredients are on
it then I'm putting it in the oven and
my is are these ovens that kind of roll
and now what's it worth between the roll
and cook ovens versus the I'm gonna open
this flap put it in there the biggest
difference is that the heat comes out to
you like in the open the door oven which
is a deck oven heat transfers from a
really hot piece of metal or stone to
the pan or to the crust right wears on a
rolling oven hot air like convection
forced convection air transfers heat so
you get a very different style of bake
fortunately for Detroit style pizza
which is only baked in a pan the
differential in pizza properties is not
as large as for instance like you
couldn't make pizza hacker style pizza
and a mannequin very build up now
that Pizza project that I did when Mark
and I first started working on this we
are trying to figure out how to make New
York style or how to make like thin
crust neo Neapolitan style pizza in a
conversion that can't happen you can't
make Neapolitan south pieces how dare
you got very hard we got way harder we
got close because there are some pretty
incredible pans that were designed to
achieve that interesting but it actually
turned out that the issue there was that
that company was building a style of
pizza that required a different level of
skill that would have be needed to make
the type of dough that could perform
that right in that on it so it's not
impossible but for that business it
wasn't the right fit and these are I
mean you're cooking these fast these for
the style how fast are we cooking a pie
nine and a half minutes nine and a half
minutes for the style right that pan
pizza yeah it generally cooks longer
like a Pizza Hut pizza hacker these
places that's in there for like two or
three minutes tops
two three minutes yeah because they're
very frost yes that debt is just
transferring massive amounts of heat to
it's essentially like a liquid right
dough is like a liquid it's like water
and flour and so the second is you're
getting people their pizzas in under 15
minutes yes you're yeah yeah yeah
exactly and that's why it's you know
fast casual style so then um what's a
oven set at like 450 Fahrenheit is it
not that spicy 550 so it is hot because
it's cooking fast yeah and then is it
then are there covers on the sides are
like are the is the line getting a
little bit of heat nothing I mean we're
sweat and water cooking so we have an
exhausted its required by law it has an
error cert so it pulls hot air up the
hood and then it's theoretically pulling
cool air from outside pushing it down
you know to to displace the air that's
kind of nasty so it's pulling hot air
pushing cold air in you helping you guys
out okay pulling hot air and like grease
and fumes and saying recent huge yeah
okay okay so then when the now this is
yeah I guess this is a question that it
isn't we talked to us a little bit
before but it doesn't make it's hard to
know this is there ever a time where you
got to pull the pizza out and then add
an ingredient on to it that only needs
to cook for two or three minutes instead
of the whole nine yeah we're gonna do
that yeah yeah it's because that adds
complication it's harder yeah so let
every one of the reasons we chose this
style pizza is because you can still
achieve this like awesome product that
has a lot of like oh this is like took a
lot of work which of course it does but
it's like some places where they crack
an egg on it or you spin it a hundred
times like those things what might do
they broke yeah but it's not an
interesting one but those things like
require a lot of expertise and skill and
that's the thing like before we were
talking about the dough process and
you're like okay you take it out you
push it on the pan then you
in the oven like now like all these
places were there stretching pizza
someone has to know how to stretch pizza
which sure
thousands of people are compete syria's
every every year and they learn how but
it's a scale it's a skill that needs to
be done right and there's a there's a
steep learning curve yeah our pizza has
a lower learning curve at almost every
level of the product right yeah hey guys
Carlo who's watching wants to know if
there's anything specific about your
square picture that's different from the
other square pieces in the Bay Area yeah
yeah yeah yeah well I don't know what
other people are doing but ours the
dough itself the formulas like really
high hydration like a high percentage of
water to flour which allows it to be
that area sort of coffee closer to
focaccia style you can tell when you
when I when we're ripping that apart
that slice that you can tell it it has
been closed over focaccia profiles right
yeah yeah I think higher hydration dough
theoretically digests a little bit
better because the glutens better broken
down mmm
we also traditionally Detroit style
pizza is one cheese one kind of like
basis Johnson which is Wisconsin brick
which is a buttery mozzarella
somewhere in monstrovia and cheddar we
do cheddar on the outside mozzarella on
the inside no one else is doing that to
our knowledge I guess so yeah yeah yeah
okay and then thanks no questions your
question Carl our thanks no square cake
flour over and give it a try yeah give
it a try and then so then how about like
okay this parts also a little bit on the
more complicated side but then you have
a you know you have them margin that you
have you have to make a margin in order
to be able to be profitable like perch
or a month you know for a month and
especially like you know per day you
also want to you know be turned profit
these are very important things for you
guys to be able to sustain yourselves
the people that are also working there
to make people happy with purchasing the
pieces all this type of stuff
so then how does one go through a
process of like determining that like
you have this amount of overhead costs
you can almost calculate it out per hour
yeah but you have to be selling a
certain amount of pizza pies per hour
yeah breakeven your number of pies
really keeps us up at night we trade off
who has the X essential stretch your
show right now show the be her I've had
it for like two days last week and yeah
he was asleep so the amount of
high-score power is what like what's
that number yeah you have to have like
50 is about 200 pizzas per night plus if
like 20% Oh 200 per night if 20% of
those sales is in beer and wine okay
there's a trickle effect with our other
menu items well okay yeah the trickle
effect interesting see you had all the
nuance down I mean at all the [ __ ]
circling back and we're pitching you
like pies per hour that's like a sexy
metric yeah but no business can be
really simplified to a metric that's
small especially something like the
restaurant is the beer and wine also so
you guys you guys get a carryover for
that license from the previous yeah well
that's we get it we got a sweet battle
we had some incredible advices to like
like look like someone was like I think
you guys opened your restaurant like
it's M seems like faster than a lot of
people open the restaurant recipes we
were super we were super fortunate that
a lot of the hurdles that restaurant to
his face to keep them from getting open
we're either already overcome or we had
like I guess just like the to chill
inspectors in the city sorry city of San
Francisco everyone's chill you're all
great also they're up to par and also we
like did their research and like took
their feedback and I responded in kind
you also hear like crazy stories of
someone's like why don't you have a hand
sink here and then you're like because
it's like an upstairs locker area where
we just store flour and they're like
they're like whatever what a crazy story
do you guys deliver yeah we're gonna get
there yes yeah
let's yeah we're gonna get there yeah
that's a little deliver that answer
abrasion look deliver that answer
shortly yeah well yeah so you know we
look we talk more about product mix then
like the highest per hour look I think
if we can fit eight hundred dough's in
our walk-in right now and we can fit
another hundred and twenty on the line
yeah yeah that would be like it that
very much and then profitable whatever
you want to do Mort I mean like we we
have a spreadsheet that was sort of our
like moderate level that would blow
those projections out that would be an
incredibly profitable business so about
a pie a minute it's a good rate of
selling for you guys that would put you
guys had pretty good yes but keep in
mind to like it doesn't it's not linear
like that right yeah there's like
comments over nine three hours some
people eat yeah there's food and
beverage sales
you called it a product mix yes yeah so
it's he mix what it's called Ava
industry I mean what's your baby he
mixes yes he literally just said it's
like repoint what you sell what
percentage of sales either why is what
and then it also it's like a cross
matrix of how much it costs you produce
that item how much the overhead is for
that item
how hard it is for your business to
produce that item or keep it in stock
right you can actually have specific
items that cost you money that aren't
even that profitable that are like an
ingredient on a pizza or something or
and but versus other items yeah that are
yeah that are some somewhere profitable
right yeah it sounds like he make this
crazy yeah yeah to figure that out okay
all right now let's do both delivery and
let's do this simulation brought to you
by sponsored reach out the simulation
Sousa Gmail document if you want that
you want that clog y'all should look up
the ad for the crispy crust to Jordans
cuz they like throw it on the table
oh it let's is a the cut back from SNL
anyway okay so teachers this is an
they're another huge complicated part of
food the food business is figuring out
if you're gonna deliver or not if you're
going to deliver through a third party
or if you're gonna deliver yourselves
how you're going to handle the backend
of processing with drivers yeah I'll
kind of talk about it pinions versus the
fact if you're like just because like
some people it's like a segment of
intoxicants versus facts opinions you
should put both socks on like what no
like you know there's a good question
it's a big debate I mean I think in this
specifically in a city like San
Francisco or any like big metro area
where this high-rise buildings and
people come home from work and sit down
and turn on Netflix you're you're
missing out it in a big way if you're
not going to delivery or they don't have
a plan to or don't have the ops to make
that work that that's a big deal that's
part of why we got this box designed for
ourselves and because if it goes to
someone's house and let's say you go to
your friend's house and you see this
awesome box what's that pizza it's
recognizable it ties back to the brand
like those things are all thought out
and I also think that competition leads
to better pricing so there's all these
different competitors in that space we
just kind of waited and waited to find
the right company that would negotiate
with us someone on the rights like
there's a big discussion in the
restaurant industry about third party
delivery and how they're like hurting
restaurants and not helping them and
it's just kind of like Groupon 10 years
ago yeah everyone loved Groupon for a
minute and then Groupon like blue
companies out of the water because they
weren't ready to handle the ops that
yeah kind of deal with give somebody all
right so now these these businesses
ubereats and post my text editor like
we're gonna bring you this much revenue
and this and that it's like cool I
wicked revenue because right we can turn
them on but what's the Associated cost
and you know we're lucky enough to have
networked and met people who can
introduce us to the right people within
those companies and we're able to work
out a pretty good deal with one of their
providers and we'll be doing it starting
in August but we're not handling it
yourself not dealers oh that's a big
deal for a company restaurant to try and
do delivery themselves versus used
there's two there's two types of
restaurants that historically handle
their own delivery pizza yeah and
Chinese food yep interests and nowadays
if you're launching a pizza restaurant
you could do your own delivery there's
plenty of like POS systems that are set
up to help you with that blah blah but
our core competency is not logistics
core competency is creating an
incredible experience and building a
really good brand and make really good
[ __ ] food and like getting it to other
people or someone else's job yeah and I
don't we think that people are willing
we've seen in the marketplace that
people are willing to pay some of
somewhat of a premium to have someone
else handle that yeah so it'd be like a
three dollar or something or $5 for yeah
delivery at our pop-up PA we're paying
$8 to door - door - put on without
without our involvement right we're -
and we realize it like like I'm a price
conscious dude this is sandwich this
Hill like I feel like everything I knew
about pricing we're still learning a lot
well what's not interesting sidenote as
people come in and say like the piece is
expensive which I mean I get it
like there's there's bargain pizza
there's all sorts of everything within
the spectrum of foods you can buy
there's a whole range on every level of
course but it can help the commute from
Stockton yeah yeah yeah okay and then
what about on and just a quick also
thing door - today was under a little
bit of yeah what happened well they're
just so under a little bit of a
magnifying lens people are looking at
the way that they're processing tips and
pain you know all of those services are
it's it's yeah interesting to me yeah
cuz how much of the tips are actually
going to the drivers when they're not
cash versus women eh I mean do they I
mean that's a Darrell it's it's C but
these are the complicated things like
you guys want to make sure companies are
not just profiting privateer for
shareholders but also that are yeah all
these types of things as a restaurant
business so usually sure there's a
strategic decision to be made and take
care of your people which is that there
are more restaurants than there ever
have been and yeah it's really hard to
keep good people and so whatever you can
do as a business to make people have to
make your people happy to support them
when it's so expensive to live in this
Bay like yeah make sure holders happy in
the short term but keep them happier in
the long term and keep great people as
historians yeah yeah
and then what about corporate corporate
events yeah yeah oh yeah I mean this we
should have done this before we did a
round of investment because we could
just play this video yeah yeah we have a
great location like we're right by so
many startups I mean also like a couple
of our investors work of these companies
they're friends of ours they were thing
works the right way they want to bring
us in for their own personal reasons so
I mean I've heard someone came in last
week saying like we were blowing up on
their slack Channel yeah great you know
a huge yeah it is huge those things are
real I mean we we have to again like
forget the number that Danny threw out
200 a day like that's a great number of
course we want to hit it yeah but we
have to do more than that to do what we
really need to do restaurants are best
when they're so busy they're busting at
the seams yeah that's one restaurants
are the most effective it's what people
like working at the most ya care people
the most yeah like in this hyper flow
state of working an Epsilon
yeah people are coming in and enjoying
it I don't know yeah and also like I
think it's it's you have to set up your
operation to work for that yeah so we've
never said well that'll be hard that'll
be impossible but we should do it anyway
it's like we've been very careful to
your point about like pulling stuff out
of the oven putting stuff in the only
variation from our operations and that
pizza oven is that our monkey bread
which is a dessert oh yeah has brown
sugar on it and if it starts the hole if
it goes through the whole cycle it burns
yeah so we open a little window on our
oven
but that is like science that's like the
biggest variation will do and we've
talked about especially it if we get to
a second store with a bigger oven maybe
converting one of into a different
temperature setting something like that
yeah but that's not where right now yeah
totes
okay so then fulfilling corporate orders
is also on the yeah I think the stages
for us or launch delivery yep then
launch lunch well actually we're open
our upstairs we have an upstairs area
that we haven't opened yet which we're
gonna announce like a really cool event
to do open that up
launch delivery pretty soon after that
and then launch in-house do a launch out
the door for catering awesome locators
been seven days a week
booms and seven days a week I mean yeah
I mean you guys have to sleep you know
yes the thing you gotta train people
that how do you give people what they
need for their own health and happiness
and well-being financially and all this
type of stuff so that you at least
travel with it I mean yes salsas are we
both took huge pay cuts really yeah yeah
this is our babies it's a little
different but I mean Ron and I making no
money every month is still over and over
again oh speaking of which you know if
you guys need maybe part-time help I got
some background in the food service and
pizza making interest rod do not test me
because I I will be back tomorrow I'll
be back tomorrow for you are arriving
yeah anyone who's come by to for a job
would live closed for like you know
people nearby if you guys want um you
know work at arms for pie guys so but
can we run we're trying to build a
culture right now yeah we're trying to
like there's excitement right now and
our team is we're a week old yep we're
getting some good press we're gonna get
busier really
you know but yeah I think we are it
looks like we're gonna get busy over the
next couple months and they're gonna be
part of that growth that's gonna be
really excited yeah yes yes and then I
think the hardest thing is we already
have to start looking at how we can
bring in some management help and we
knew that we knew we were gonna start
with a GM like word I'm the just fall
start yeah I guess semi chef de cuisine
executive chef though like Marc really
oversees the pizza side of the world but
like we knew that we were gonna have to
have bring in someone to oversee
production in the morning
yep because we can't be in both places
and it's like service where guests are
there it needs a lot I mean today's an
interesting example like Dan twig we
forgot that we were like oh we're gonna
do this podcast at 4:30 and then you
text us and we're like oh crap and then
we had of like closed everything up get
all that prep done and like spray it in
every day since we've opened
she's been money here spray we had we've
had three of our pre-shift
meanings after 4 p.m. well guess they're
like wait like my giveaway was like just
wings your guests in steel or cash ready
to go yeah they should to go wrong and
but like that's I mean bursting at the
seams like you said so what that is like
the staffing like we've we hired like we
were fortunate to find people that we
were able to hire and felt like the
right fit yeah some of those people have
been less yeah and appropriate we had at
least three people that accept a job
then didn't show up the next day it's
like one guy kept saying he's like I'm
coming tomorrow right okay I won't say
his name but he kept saying he's gonna
come the next day yeah I don't think he
said all the 15 minutes away he said I'm
15 minutes but it's fine like we these
are hard stuff but we knew we knew that
it doesn't make it easier but we at
least we knew it like we share the load
and we know what we can each
individually handle so like there's that
but you know and I'm I have experience
managing kitchens while having a heavy
admin load yeah like I'll sit at the
counter and trainer prep cook in Spanish
well I do have my work yeah that's crazy
yeah it is crazy it's [ __ ] damn yeah
buen trabajo
yeah yeah crazy that's a lot of hats
guys this has been epic talking about
all the different aspects of square pie
guys two quick questions on the way out
that we like asking our guests so I are
we in a simulation yeah sometimes it
doesn't feel real sometimes it really
feels like like to Mark's point about
synchronicity and your point about like
so many little individual things like
since I was like 25 when I started to
want to get out of restaurants have led
me to this point like there are so many
little coincidences or like nuances that
that had to happen for this to happen
where I'm like but I just thought that
was like a thing I wanted to do and now
yeah you're right yeah no I don't know
that answers your question but when you
were picking the pizza part and talking
about the crumb structure and like I had
weird like deja vu like I feel like I've
visioned that moment before oh yeah it
was very strange it was like I was less
the bread more of like the way that
broccoli was hanging off yes I was like
I feel like I have ID on this or like I
don't know I kind of don't really care
like my I feel like I just I mean I
don't care like if it is great my
consciousness is still the same thing
like if I die I don't think I'm gonna
like be able to look back and be like oh
[ __ ] it wasn't what I thought it was I'm
just gonna be dead that's how that's my
belief system so [ __ ] it if it is it is
like but we're here you're gonna keep
leveling up and being our best yeah
we're doing this totally and last
questions what do you guys think is the
most beautiful thing in the world oh
[ __ ] laughter like brevity just making
like why I mean life you heard my view
on the world in the beginning life is
kind of [ __ ] up and weird and we all
go through [ __ ] and have trauma and pain
and whatever and I think the universal
solve is like laughter and empathy and
those two things are like kind of all we
got there the end of the day I think a
lake at the top with Sierra Nevada at
the end of hike and I hike a lot
a little ice rod that's seven mile hike
up there like crest it and there's still
cold water in your water bottle and
there's just like a lake or something
like that yeah there's a lot there's a
lot of stimulation like yeah there's
like a lot of my backstory that gets to
that kind of like physical but also
metaphorical dream I said that was
really cool the way that you guys had
there your two answers it's a very like
Geographic like this like these
beautiful things so that have flourished
on earth and the other one is like this
human interaction and laughter yeah
these types of things I love that um you
guys mark Danny this has been so cool
Thank You Danny for coming and delicious
and delicious yeah I'm a got a new Cubs
I wanna I also want to come in for an
evening to get my hands on things that
you also worked in the business it's a
very fun thing totally yeah yeah yeah we
got to do it around the show dude around
the show dates
alright thanks everyone for tuning in we
greatly appreciate it of to hear your
thoughts in the comments below on this
episode let us know what you're thinking
about this modern pizza moving about
square pie guys about the complexities
of turning an idea into brick-and-mortar
and how you can actually do that in such
a short period of time also check out
the links in the bow below to square pie
guys and their Instagram gonna follow
them and oh and also thanks around
Vargas for producing and directing we
really appreciate it Ron Ron right and
support the artists entrepreneurs that
spiritual leaders the organizations
around the world that you believe and
support them help them grow support
simulation our links are below support
us PayPal patreon cryptocurrency all
those links are blurred design cool
merch and get paid and go and build the
future everyone manifest your dreams
into the world you love me very much
thank you for tuning in and we will see
you soon
you
[Music]